so one of the fossils that they began to
find was this a trilobite
and that's actually what otto was was
drawing over here the trilobite began to
emerge in the Cambrian and the Silurian
so they're very very old and Americans
began to find these in the railroad cuts
that they were making through the rocks
of the United States they began to talk
to people in England who were also
finding trilobite and they began for the
first time now again we take this for
granted but it was not until the 1830s
that people in Britain and the Americas
began to imagine that those two areas of
land had once been connected so this is
a new geological understanding of a past
that is beginning to stretch very far
back in time so next time you see a
trilobite be excited about it the the
Industrial Revolution is also important
because they are finding evidence of a
time in the past in Earth's history that
was full of what they now called and
this is a new term coined in the 1830s
fossil fuels fossil fuels is a term that
is coined in the early 19th century
precisely during the deep time
revolution
they're cutting through the earth
they're looking for fuel to power the
Industrial Revolution they find an era a
lost era full of palm trees from a time
when the whole earth was like the Amazon
a kind of what they called a
Carboniferous an era of carbon and this
was going to become
here's another key word from this time
period the natural resource that would
power the Industrial Revolution so the
Industrial Revolution the cars the
trains are all part of the new ways of
approaching the earth that helped get us
to deep time ok deep time is great but
it brings up a bunch of new problems and
these are so interesting and I give them
to you not as me telling you what to
think but as partners with me in
thinking about how difficult this is to
think about so deep time presents a
number of issues let me just give you
the first one
the first thing is the deep time is an
inconceivable concept Charles Darwin is
one of the many people in the 19th
century who thinks about deep time right
evolution has to happen over deep time
and he says it is in comprehensively
vast he is one of many others who look
at the idea of deep time that the earth
is not 6,000 but maybe 10 million 20
million 4 billion years old
and says that maybe so but I cannot
conceive of that so it's this startling
new concept that by its very nature is
an inconceivable concept so this is
wonderful for historians like me who
like to imagine how people think about
their world to imagine a new idea that
you cannot think about is an absolutely
extraordinary thing that is very very
fun for us to think about so deep time
also has a second problem with it which
is that it is existentially horrifying
one thing we know about human beings is
that we like to be the center of the
universe nothing matters unless we are
part of it unless we are folded into our
own history of the universe and the
history of the earth it's hard to
understand why it should matter and deep
time presents this problem in a really
really palpable way the Bible ultimately
is about human beings and how you get
from then to now and the Bible has at
its very center the sense that human
beings are God's special creation deep
tongue does not have that assurance it
removes humanity from the story of life
on Earth from the story of Earth from
the story of the cosmos you can have as
many strata as you want but if none of
them contain human beings and if none of
them contain the things that human
beings are good at doing which is having
a
right we have events we have events like
this one and events leave documents they
leave traces in the historical record
none of those are present in these
strata so the strata present to people
who could not before had imagined
anything longer than a 6,000 year
history that was in a document it was in
the Bible the Bible had nothing to say
about strata so this was very very
unsettling a book in which we were not
even the act not not just not Act not
the main actors but not actors at all in
it so what do you do to fix this problem
well in the nineteenth century we see a
number of solutions emerging to this
problem which is to try to make the
inconceivable concept of deep time
conceivable not only conceivable but as
we saw with the slinky unwinding of the
Earth's history in the thing that you're
gonna look at later on when you go home
to make it beautiful to make it
relatable to make it in some ways part
of our own humanity when in fact we know
deep down down inside that deep time
doesn't really have humanity necessarily
as part of it so what do some of these
images look like some of these are gonna
be familiar to you but I hope that from
now on you look at them as the evidence
of the the birth of deep time so this is
one of the many images to come out of
some of the Grand Canyon exploring
expeditions of the 1870s 1880s and 1890s
this is William Henry Holmes painting of
the Grand Canyon this is incredible
right this is like strata central
looking down into the Grand Canyon you
see all of these layer cakes of time and
look at these tiny tiny human beings
they're totally insignificant in this
larger canvas but it is so
incredibly beautiful that you don't care
and it is so incredibly beautiful and
I'm just giving you things to think
about right you don't have to agree with
me just think about is bear with me it's
so incredibly beautiful that even though
it is existentially horrifying even
though we as human beings are
insignificant we imagine that perhaps
something like the deity might be there
because it is so transcendently
beautiful and it makes us think about
eternity in the way that people in the
18th century and before thought about
eternity so one way to think about deep
time images is as the secularization of
the crisp the judeo-christian idea of
the cosmic eternity in the face of the
scientific revolutions of the 18th and
19th century
[Music]